all right adriana
yeah adriana where'd you grow up where
are you from originally chicago illinois
and tell me about your family how you
had both your parents growing up
uh not really um
when i was born i had about up to the
age of four years old i remember
um it was kind of rough it was rocky
they fought a lot they really bumped
heads a lot
um there's something that happened
where my uncle had to beat my father
near death with a baseball bat so i
don't know whatever that
but how was how would you describe your
childhood um
[Music]
touched sexually charged um
overly
i guess this is kind of kind of
a little unstable rocking up and down
you know
roller coaster right but um
very studious i was as stuck as
well-rounded you know humble beginnings
just like any other um chicago native
inner city south side or west side south
side
you know ghetto yeah
and uh any
sorry any abuse
yes lots like sexual physical yes
all the above yeah and who
did that come from of people that my mom
knew through my mom drug users through
my mom
at what age did this kind of pushers the
sexual abuse would start at what age
like five six six seven
and up with men yeah well i mean well
one was with this teenage girl and her
little
brother but it was weird kind of but it
was
just like ugh whatever something i got
over it
it only happened once so i didn't really
pay too much attention
to it but um how many instances
the older male
touchings and i guess um
it sounds like this is it's just that
something repetitive
routines you know until i would move
away
and not you know then you moved your way
to where here in indiana to gary
yes and what what was your life
what was your life all about when you
were in gary and gary
um things kind of took a turn
for the better um
i got a taste of the um
i guess the normal
everyday kid you know going to school
every day
getting ready for you when you moved
here i was about
six six five
third grade fourth grade you finished
high school oh yeah i did i finished
high school
um got technical
graduate and on travel
after school you did what after school i
went to um
the travel academy
for flight attendants and cruise line
work and
relations work it was great it was
phenomenal i love it did you work as a
flight attendant
no but i got to taste it you know
interviewing the interview process
that's all i wanted to do right then and
there i really want to get my feet wet
in the
the cruising industry first and i did
but um during this you know i guess
training and the this climbing of the
ladder and corporate ladder in this
industry and field and cover 19
has struck twice and
uh my contract was canceled again
so yeah since you've been in l.a
what what kind of work have you done to
support yourself just hospitality
i had one warehouse job andrew christian
warehouse and boutique i really like
that show
um but all the others were um hotels
and things and a lot a lot of the trans
women that i've interviewed
have done sex work have you i have
well for my first couple of
three years living here but
recently i've stopped doing that for
them predominantly like like faithfully
for two years straight and i made it my
um objective and my goal and my
priority to just not do it just to avoid
it all together i just want to avoid it
right there for what reason because i
just that's
just not the life for me and then it's
just honestly it's
there's not enough money the money is
it's it's the money is too
it's too flimsy it's not lucrative
enough
it's not um steady
i would not really assume it's all it's
not reliable i would also assume
emotionally it's got to be difficult to
do that kind of work
oh yeah i started and days it i did it
so much to the point where days i would
start to question my
worth and you know question
my um humanity i guess
like that makes sense am i human am i a
piece of meat
am i you know
something expendable like what's my
worth i just i started losing sense of
my value
as a human period yeah
that makes perfect sense
yeah but i kept strong because you know
i was like i was determined
i was determined to get on my feet out
here and
try to find a way you know on my own
so you're staying on skid row now no i
i've got an apartment
through skid row housing trust right so
you're in one of the sros
yes on skid row um on siri
yeah yeah that's good riley you could
say that yeah skid row
um and how do you support yourself now
my ssi ssdi
and my edd i could still collect that
because i was working enough to
collect it what are your goals from here
to get
i would like to try to find some way to
get back into my you know
my technical career
the travel industry has taken too much
of a
hit with this pandemic and i've already
lost
you know another chance with my contract
with princess cruises
because canada doesn't want any cruise
ships
um they're not allowing any
you know one to pass through their water
so
i'm without a job if i can't get um
gig and um takina
but otherwise going back to princess
cruises
and um yeah
it's not gonna look that's not looking
too grand it's
promising this year are drugs a part of
your life
yes yes yes i i hate to say it but yes
but just dealing with life and coping
which is your which is your favorite
the one that helps me with my sexual um
traumas
and my sexual um inadequacies
first of all yes
also it helps with my personality
disorder and my characteristics
and a lot of my mannerisms
as a whole you know it helps me be
confident when i rather be timid and
cowardly
courageous even you know
it gives me a tenacity of some guts at
least
i like to look at it that way
i've heard people say it makes them
bolder
yeah i like to say that yeah
liquid courage i guess crystal courage
you still talk to your family yes i do
how was your relationship like that
it's very good it's it's it's very very
traditional loving
caring stern strict
discerning it's very um
it's it's like it's like it's like
it's like the tribes it's like a tribe
you know it's like it's a village to
raise a child
but your family is supportive of your
lifestyle and
oh they don't look at my lifestyle they
look at me as
one of their kinfolk one of their
relatives one of their bloodlines that's
great
their generation their offspring you
know their
sibling yeah
that's great they see me as
relative period all the other stuff
that's my personal
business what are the struggles for
being a trans woman
for me today um for me personally
my personal relation my love life
my sex life is it hard to find a partner
my relationships
as a whole it's just it's just it's
really hard
being the person that i am and being the
libra and
i am addicted to social
like sociality i'm addicted to
you know friendships and relationships
and
intimacy and companionship and you know
compassion intimacy romance and
affection you know i desire
lawlessness and and being sexually
charged at such a young age
now it's like it's like mount vesuvius
then
it's like a never ending i guess
and then on crystal meth that amplifies
everything right
no for me it makes
it helps and i guess it helps
if i do it right in moderation that i do
and not go back to my old behaviors
which i have
really but it's hard because nowadays
every
everything's changing so rapidly it's
like
it's better just me to keep to myself or
either
keep to whom i know i can you know trust
i guess
do you feel like the sexual abuse that
you experience as a child
help change or change the direction of
your life in some way
um yes
yes um
it played a big part of me hating like
disliking
myself a lot and feeling
disgusted within my um
arousals and desires and sexual
chemistry i guess
a shame guilt you know humiliated
you know disgusting
seems to me all forms of abuse sexual
physical emotion
do the same thing which is um
or something like it's like i'm damaged
and
damaged like i'm discarded goods
pretty much
it's hard to overcome that
so that low self-worth that you pick up
from that right
i'm going to i'm not um
[Music]
that helps me not a victim it wasn't my
fault
and um
i need to give that child a chance
you know it's great to hear that child
to
you know love that child who was alone
when their mother was chasing the next
fix or you know hit what not
or getting beat down and bruised
you know sexually misused by the next
pushing me and or
dope dude or dope [ __ ] whatever the
case you want to call it or whatever
i don't know i just
i just thank god
for anointing her with the holy spirit
to drive herself and put that will in
her
to get herself clean and
come back and be the mother that
i need her to be she did that at what
age for you
33. you were 33 when your mom got
cleaned
she was 33 she was pretty sick
and because of that she was able to
raise me
in good church of bringing like deep
rooted church religion
um
great education like she she was a very
very academic
academic parent like she was a huge
huge scholar scholastic
academic parent like the whole the whole
um
parent-teacher conference type parent
parent was
it pta pta meetings she loved the pta
meetings the bake sale
the block party his son loves my mother
she's my best friend that's great
and what's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life
to love myself
that's it to forgive myself and love
myself
and and and don't be afraid
to
live life on lifetime
be be be ready and willing to
to live on life terms because
life is going to happen it's happening
now
yes it is all right adriana thank you so
much for sharing your story
thank you i wish you the best of luck
you too thank you for having me
you